for a second time this month French
workers and unions took to the streets
across the country in their hundreds of
thousands against planned pension
reforms and public sector strikes tore
into the economy affecting the energy
grid transport education and Health
Services there were minor scuffles
between some protesters and police and
tension is likely to grow with more days
of protest like this ahead as the
government tries to raise the pension
age from 62 to 64 and to increase the
period of compulsory workplace
contributions to compensate for a
population that is living longer it's
both both unfair and unnecessary and
fair because it's actually asking
waiting the much effort on the poorests
because they're the ones that are going
to have to work more and then they're
the ones with the shortest life
expectancy and it's unnecessary because
the deficit that the government is
claiming is justifying to base its
reform on is only temporary and you
could just tax two percent of French
billionaire wealth to actually plug the
deficit so it's just a political Choice
reform of France's social welfare system
including pensions is a signature policy
of the second Emmanuel macron presidency
it could be that a signature feature
becomes public protest like the yellow
vest demonstrations against Rising fuel
prices that blighted macron's first term
but we are thinking about the future we
are taking part in this protest because
the bigger the numbers the more likely
things can change at least that's what
we hope
we're thinking about our parents we
don't want them to work for longer they
have already broken their backs enough
64 years is intolerable the government
says pension reform is not just
necessary but inevitable and as these
policies make their way through the
National Assembly in February this
Centrist minority government will likely
Prevail with the help of the
conservative right or be it probably not
with President macron's popularity
intact Jonah Holt Al Jazeera Paris